back in the channel 8 phone bank
answering your questions about medicare
eligibility that's the phone number on
the screen these folks are going to be
here until seven tonight meantime we've
got to dr moayad ismail
and let's talk about the enrollment and
and how people can make the process
easier thanks for having me um first of
all you got to remember that your
insurance plays the biggest role here
they pay for your cost your medical care
they give you access to your doctor your
urgent care visits your hospital your
x-rays labs case managers
everything all right and then beyond
that beyond the ease of it you have a
network that's unique yeah so southwest
medical is a proud part of optum care
nevada
we
have over 400 providers in
you know 40 different locations in
southern nevada and we've been serving
our community here for
more than 50 years we're the biggest
multi-specialty group here you get
access to 60 minute annual exams you get
access to 24 7 telephonic advice nurse
line phone number and you get 24 7
urgent care visits through your now
clinic portal
and
go from there all right dr ismael thank
you so much phone numbers on your screen
these folks are here until seven tonight
we'll be right